we all went through this 15-month period
but i know that i ran into oh
remember i'm trying to remember it was
because
we sort of lived near each other uh up
at the beach and i
let me remind you yeah please remind me
i need so many celebrities
it's peak of pandemic july 4th weekend
um my husband decides to procure
fireworks legally
and um and we're like listen it's for
the kids
no one's here you know we'll just set
them off on the beach it's gonna be safe
he's from iowa he knows how to do this
so we are setting off said fireworks
and uh no one's on the beach i mean it
is nobody there and all of a sudden
fireworks are like and then we see this
but with like a hoodie just like
i'm not mr burns on the simpsons
started you literally walked in like
this
well first of all that's my usual
expression yeah yeah
okay he does that when he sees people
enjoying themselves yeah
i'm like the grinch yeah but it's dark
yeah
it was hard to like fully understand
what was happening but i was with a
friend of mine at the time and she
turned to me she goes
oh no i was like oh my god someone's
coming towards us we're gonna get in
trouble
this person's coming coming just kind of
stains they're next to the pew pew
fireworks
and uh and she goes oh my god it's coded
i'm ryan and i was like oh yeah that
makes sense
do you remember i ran towards you yeah
and i was gonna hug you
yeah and i was like hey oh hey
hey like all of a sudden i was like i
don't know how to but you know what
women were doing that to me long before
the pandemic
my whole life has been hacked yeah and
we're good
we're good uh no it was so emotional and
it was so funny because
you're not describing you're not
describing accurately these were not
these fireworks i don't know where
ashton went to a don't legally he must
know people in the military
because the reason i came over is i saw
major explosions down the beach and i'm
on patrol you know
ashton's walking around he's like
wearing shorts and he's when they're
about done he's kicks over a giant cam
with his boot
it's just being from iowa i'm not from
iowa so for me i was like
this is wrong and he was like i got this
yeah and like set up a whole course
of legally purchased fireworks yeah
these were the safest fireworks i've
ever seen that's for sure
[Music]
i do not walk around like that i did
with the hoodie
okay well whatever you know i gotta hide
this thing you know